You have to be persistent.
You have to, you know,
listen to all the no's,
which we got many, many of
and then just keep pushing forward.
Bring as much passion
as you can to something,
lead with your heart,
build the right team,
the right management team,
and then just build upon that
and it starts to snowball.
And that's really what
we did at Beyond Meat.
Well, look, I'm honored to have you here
and I must start off by saying
that I'm a proud investor
and I have to let you know, Ethan,
that you have a lot to do
with why I went plant-based to begin.
You one of the first
examples I always go to
when talking about the
impact this can have
on someone's life
and just you as role model for kids.
It's been amazing, even
aside from Beyond Meat,
the carbon footprint and everything.
Now getting onto some
of the questions Ethan.
So you started off in clean tech.
I did.
How and why?
Yeah, so when I was younger
and I had love a for basketball,
but not the same talent as you do
so we had to go do something else.
And I was sitting in my dad's office
and I was talking about kind
of what I should be doing
as I thought about my career.
You know, he asked me a question.
He asked me, "What is the
biggest problem in the world
as you see it?"
And I thought about that for a long time.
And to me, it really came
back as being climate.
And so the correlate to
that question was, you know,
then what do you do about it?
And at the time,
the thinking was really
around alternative energy.
So looking at ways to
migrate from fossil fuels to
renewable and cleaner sources of energy.
And there was kind of a basket
of different technologies,
whether it was lithium ion
batteries, solar cells,
wind, fuel cells, and I began
working on a number of those
as a kind of analyst
and then joined a company
that was focused on
hydrogen powered, specifically,
proton exchange membrane fuel cells.
And I loved it. I loved
working in that space.
But I kept feeling that
I was missing something.
And that led me to the
work that I'm doing now.
How does clean tech get you to food?
Like how did that happen?
I mean, first of all,
what we're talking about
in clean energy is fuel
to move things around, to warm buildings,
to provide the electricity
that we so enjoy,
and things of that nature.
What we're talking about in
food is fuel for our bodies.
And so there are some
common elements there,
but more importantly,
it was through problem solving.
I began to really think more about climate
in maybe a more
sophisticated way than I had
when I was just a student
and started to think about
the impact that livestock
has on climate.
And to me, just the sheer
amount of land, energy, water,
and emissions that are involved
in bringing a piece of
protein to the plate
from an animal that was so significant
that I felt I had to go
do something about it.
It's one thing to know
all of those working parts
and all the different intricacies.
Like me, once I started
eating healthy, right,
I started trying to figure
out what foods to eat.
But you got Beyond Meat, right?
Like what inspired you, right.
If you think about what meat is,
and this is really where I
think things get exciting.
Meat is a composition that
is very familiar to us
and it's essentially five things
if you think about it
at a really high level.
It's amino acid, it's
lipids, it's trace minerals,
it's vitamins, and it's water.
Said more simply, it's basically
protein, fat, and water.
And what the animal's doing is
they're consuming a large
amount of vegetation.
You know, you look at Bovine,
they're eating grass or being fed feed.
And they're converting that plant material
through their digestive tract
and their skeletal muscular system
into a center of the plate
protein, into muscle, right.
And we harvest that muscle
as we slaughter the animal,
pull it out,
and then we prepare that as something
we put at the center of our plate.
Well, the tremendous news here,
and this has to do with
the evolution of the earth
and our species within it,
is that there's a commonality in a unity
between plants and animals,
in terms of the core material of parts.
So what you find in plants,
you also find in human and animal bodies
just presenting differently,
but it's that combination of proteins
and fats and water that you
can pull those from plants,
or you can get them from animals.
And our idea was to just,
not to make a soybean behave like a steak,
but rather let's find the
core parts of meat in plants.
Let's pull them from the plants
and let's assemble them
against the architecture
or blueprint of animal muscle or meat.
What was your advantage, right?
And how did you get
investors to believe in you?
Right, cause I'm sure when
you came to some people,
they were like, what is he talking about?
Like we not trying to do this.
We like to eat our meat.
We like this stuff.
What is he talking about?
How did you get investors to believe
in what you were building?
I mean, it's very similar
and this is why I love sports so much,
to what I've seen you go through.
And I obviously,
I know so much about your career as a fan
and the persistence that you had to show.
And, you know, transiting
from football to basketball.
So I think that the biggest thing,
you know, when I was in business school,
people would talk about, oh,
you need a competitive moat.
And generally they would say
that has to be some advantage
from a technology perspective
going into a sector
so that you can create
a competitive advantage
that someone else can't knock out.
And unfortunately, that's not really true.
What you do need is to
work harder than anybody,
to be smart, and surround
yourself with very smart people.
But it's not like I went into this space
with infallible technology.
I went in with a very good technology
and one that was very good
at creating muscle structure,
but it was what we've done after that,
that really has helped propel the company.
And so you have to be persistent.
You have to, you know,
listen to all the no's,
which we got many, many of,
and then just keep pushing forward.
But bring as much passion
as you can to something,
lead with your heart,
build the right team,
the right management team,
have good technology,
and then just build upon that
and it starts to snowball.
And that's really what
we did at Beyond Meat.
What was it like for you though
when you were getting those no's
and then obviously Beyond
Meat is very successful now.
Like, do you remember a lot of those no's
and it's okay to have a
chip on your shoulder?
Well, I love that.
It's funny, I just was texting
one of my children about,
they were going into practice.
I said, make sure you do play
with a chip on your shoulder
because you know,
you have to find some ways
to feel yourself every day.
And so I certainly do have that.
And in this room here,
there are quotes on the wall
from people who have doubted us.
You know, people in media
and things like that saying
that this can't be done.
And I use those a lot to motivate myself
and to motivate my team.
And so, yeah, I remember
all of 'em actually.
Where, you know, you're
sitting across from a table,
you really need someone to invest
and believe in you.
And, you know, they turn you down
and they turn you down again and again.
And you know, it's persistence
and it's a commitment to the
product at the end of the day.
Like we have to keep making
the product better and better.
And we have this program at Beyond Meat,
that's called Beyond Meat Rapid
and Relentless Innovation.
And to talk about sports again,
actually stole that word,
that use of that word,
from the warriors back when they were,
you know, just, I went to
a conference there one day
and they kept using that word.
I said, "Well, that's
really what I want this team
to be doing within our
labs is just be relentless
on being the best out there.
At taking protein fats,
minerals, vitamins, water
from non animal sources
and building them into
the structure of meat
and let's get better and better every day.
And that's the only way
to prove people wrong."
And by the way, with
these deals we just did
with McDonald's, KFC,
Pizza Hut, and Taco Bell.
Our promise to them is
that we will out compete
the other people in the market.
Like we will just bring
you the best product.
And that's how we have
to build our reputation
and how we have to build
our company is not through,
you can try to get contracts
where you force people
to take your products,
or what have you.
Better way to live
and the better way to do things is just
always produce the best product.
And so, you know, as I
was getting those no's,
I just went home and
made the product better.
Just went, you know,
worked with my team to
make the product better
and better and better.
And once you do that, at that point,
you start to see customers come to you.
You start to see investors come to you.
Being in athletics my entire life,
playing football, playing basketball,
and especially when I made it to the NBA,
everyone used to always ask the question,
when did you know that you
were gonna make it, right?
Like, you have some prodigies
that know they're gonna make it
when they're in middle school now.
And I always say for me,
I didn't know until probably
my sophomore year in college.
That's when I really was like, I'm ready.
I'm ready. I can go to the NBA.
I know I'll be ready.
When did you know that
you were onto something?
So I have this thing where
I never thought the business would fail.
I didn't know how it
would come out though.
You know, I just didn't.
You know, we talked about
how do you get through the no's and stuff,
and one of the ways is to
cut your safety net completely, right.
And I didn't necessarily
do that consciously,
but I did it anyway.
And what I mean by that is,
you know, I had a very good job
and had, you know, some savings
and home and all this stuff.
But, you know, you say, I'm
never gonna touch those savings,
but you do and you burn through them.
And then, you know,
I'm not gonna sell that
house, but you do, you know?
And so then it's not so much
bravery that keeps you going,
it's just you got to.
I'm sharing that because, you know,
even today you have to
have a healthy amount of,
I dunno if it's fear
or a belief that you
need to keep pushing hard
to be successful.
That you can't rest, right.
And so one of the things I love about,
particularly college coaches
and even NBA coaches is,
how many times you see a
NBA coach, like, you know,
smiling and dancing up
and down when they win.
They look relieved.
Like, if you look at like
Coach K when he wins,
he just looks relieved.
Right.
You know.
And that's sort of the sense of what you,
when you have a business like this
or a career like yours,
you know, oftentimes it's
just a relief to have won.
And I feel that way as
we're growing our business.
And so I would say the
moment that I felt like,
my God, this is actually turning
and this is something that
could have the global impact,
when we started getting these
large quick serve restaurants.
And so, you know,
one of the first was A&W
and then here in Southern California,
Carl's and Del Taco,
but then in Canada McDonald's.
And I went there myself,
I was in Toronto and they
did the test in a rural area.
And I got in a car late at night,
and I drove out there
and I sat down in the
restaurant and I had it.
And I got that feeling of like, you know,
really can't believe this is happening.
And that was a blessing for me.
And a wonderful feeling.
You created a product that
didn't exist before, right.
So you're an inventor.
Like, what was, you laughing about it,
but that's the truth.
Like, sometimes people will
come out with something
that already exists
and just try to make a
better version of it.
You really invented something.
So what was your biggest obstacle?
Yeah, there were a lot.
The first obstacle was myself.
You know, was just convincing myself that
well, answering a calling, basically.
You know, if I didn't do this,
would I be happy in life, you know?
And it takes a lot to get yourself out of,
you know, a routine where
you're paying for your mortgage,
you're saving money, and all that stuff,
to do something that is
outside of your field.
And so for me,
it just a discomfort started to build,
I was like, you know,
said, I really have to go do this
and satisfy this issue.
So that was the first obstacle
was getting over my own
sense of trepidation about it.
And then second,
you know, was just this
constant need to overcome,
there's a cultural barrier to this
that still exists today.
That, you know,
I think one of the reasons that
I find your work with us
and your work overall on this subject,
so incredibly compelling is
we have to displace, attack head on,
and really something that's a-scientific.
And that is that animal protein
is better for you in terms of athleticism
and everything else than planet protein.
What's true is that a complete set of
amino acid is really good for you, right,
as an athlete.
And healthy, clean fats
are really good for you.
We can take all those from plants
and build them into the structure of meat
so that you can satisfy
and grow your body and
perform at your highest level.
But yet there's a cultural stereotype
that's the exact opposite, you know.
And so, this ideas that-
Right.
To be a robust athlete
and to be a masculine presence
that you need to have animal protein,
and it's just a-scientific.
And so we had to get through that,
and we're still trying
to get through that.
And because the irony is that
if you do wanna perform
at the highest level,
cleaning your body of some of the things
that are in animal
protein is the way to go.
And so we're just learning
so much about the role
that food can play,
whether it's in, you know,
the inflammation you feel in your knees
or potential precursor
or contributor rather
to Alzheimer's disease, to heart disease.
Inflammation is the root
of so many of the things
that are causing these
diseases that are so horrific.
And we can influence those
through the food we eat,
through how it conditions our microbiome
and the bacteria in our gut.
And we can play a role
at that at Beyond Meat.
Trust me, Ethan,
everything you saying right now is,
I told you it's been life changing for me.
And I think what you're
saying is so important,
'cause it's the education component of it.
And I think that's what
so people lack in general,
but especially the African
American community.
My aunts and uncles, my dad,
I think for me, this change in lifestyle,
as far as diet and eating it,
it really hit me hard
and it started off performance based,
but then it became life based, right?
And if no one else ever listens to me
when I get on one of my rants
and talking about how to eat healthy
and what it does for your gut,
my dad turned 60 this
past year and you know,
I was driving on the highway
and my dad called me and
he called me on FaceTime
and he was in tears.
And he was just telling me
that he had went to the doctor
and the doctor has told
him that his health
was so much better, was so much better.
So, I thank you for educating me
to begin with so that I can
try to educate those around me.
So off of that moment right there,
so one of the things too,
that obviously people know is that
Beyond Meat is still more expensive than
regular meat, right?
And I know that you said
that that will flip.
Like, when and what will it
take to make that happen?
Yeah, so we set a goal two years ago
to within five years be able
to underprice animal protein
in at least one category.
And that's so important
because right now we're asking
the question of the consumer,
let's say in a quick serve restaurant
you know, do they want to transition
or substitute a plant-based
meat into their diet.
But also do they wanna pay more for it?
And we gotta get a away
from that second question.
That second question is not helpful.
And what's terrific
about what we're doing,
you know, if you believe in
this model of efficiency,
we talk about the animal
being the biggest
bottleneck in agriculture.
So we have increased the
efficiency of our fields
over the last 100 years,
an incredible amount, right?
So, you know, corn, soy, and wheat,
we're growing hugely
more quantities per acre
than ever before in human history.
But what are we doing with that?
We're running it through the same system
to convert it into meat,
which is the animal.
And the animal's largely
standing still in the sense that,
the animal's not evolving,
at a pace that we can see anyway,
into a more efficient bioreactor.
So if we remove the animal
and we put in this technology,
which takes two to three minutes
to create that muscle like structure,
we should become less expensive.
We have tremendous efficiency advantages
over animal protein.
And we had University of Michigan
do this great study where we, you know,
we use 99%, less water, 93% less land.
So why are we more expensive?
It doesn't make sense.
The inputs are, you know, plants.
They're things like peas and,
you know, faba bean,
and things that are readily
available in agriculture.
The answer has entirely to do with
the scale of our business.
So if you think about Tyson or JBS,
you know, you look at how
much food they are producing.
I heard at one point
that Tyson was touching
two out of every five
plates in the United States.
So they have a scale advantage over us
and we have to continue
to scale our business.
We have to continue to
mature our supply chain,
enter more competition
into our supply chain
so we can get lower cost inputs,
but we're doing all that now.
And we're on that cost curve.
And so if you think about
the computer industry
or the semiconductor industry,
or any of these technologies come along,
we are gonna make this cheaper
and cheaper and cheaper to the point where
we'll underprice animal protein.
Why is that so important?
For obvious reasons, but look,
we'll get closer and closer
to the animal protein that we're trying to
provide an alternative to,
in terms of the sensory experience,
the taste, the aroma, the appearance,
all of that stuff will keep
getting better every year.
Second, we'll get the
nutrition to the point where
everyone understands that point, right.
Right, now there's a lot
of noise about process
and all this stuff.
We're gonna do a lot of education about
why this product is
healthier for you, right?
So taste, health,
and then you drop the
price below animal protein,
it becomes a rare consumer that says,
"This tastes just like animal protein.
It's better for me. And it's cheaper.
I'm still not gonna eat it."
So we've gotta get those three things done
and we've gotta get 'em
done in the next few years.
Right, cause my next question was gonna be
for me, it was somewhat
easy to convert me, right.
Because the inflammation,
me being an athlete, right.
But how do you convert
the diehard meat eaters?
Independent of ideological boundaries
or, you know, socioeconomic,
all the divisions that
we have in our society.
You're still seeing people take this step
and become largely flexitarian.
And it's driven primarily by health.
You know, it doesn't matter
whether you're in a field in Idaho
or in one of the densest
urban neighborhoods
in the United States, on the coast,
or in Chicago, or what have you,
if your doctor tells you
that you are going to die
if you don't change something, right,
you're gonna listen.
And not everybody listens,
but enough people are listening
where they're breaking through
and they're setting aside stereotypes
and things that are not serving them.
And so for us, health is
the number one message.
And that differentiates us by the way,
from some of the companies
that are out there.
You know, when we talk
about our ingredients,
we say, you know, first of all,
it wouldn't be responsible
to load our product up
with high levels of saturated fat.
So we're always gonna offer the consumer,
if you look at our burger,
significantly les saturated
fat than what's in beef, right.
So we have, I think in
the Beyond Burger 3.0,
we have 35% less saturated
fat in one of the versions
and a second, which is
meant to be a lean burger,
we have 55% less saturated fat.
We have, you know, no GMOs.
So there's no,
you know, novel ingredients there.
It's just, we're using
the plant kingdom in ways
that present it to the
human-centric experience
as animal protein.
And then no heterocyclic amines
all of the things that are of concern
within the medical community
about animal protein,
we have kept out of our products, right.
Or minimized.
And so we have to keep
conveying to people,
the health benefits of eating it.
And that's the quickest
way to their plate.
Last but not least, you know,
everyone defines this differently.
What is success to you?
What is success look like to you
when it comes to you and your company?
You know, it really,
we're trying to do something.
And when I say we, you
know, we're all in this,
doing this together,
to help, you know, save lives
and help people live a healthier life.
And to help repair our planet.
Success for me is seeing
as many people as possible
in the locations that they love to eat.
And that's why I'm so focused
on places like McDonald's
and KFC and others,
enjoy themselves, enjoy the meal,
have great tasting products,
but do it in a way that's
better for their bodies
and do it in a way that's
better for the earth.
And so that's really how
we do measure success here.
It's a mission,
you know, it's something
that's very personal.
And, you know, we hope to look back
and be that group of people
that separated meat from animals
and brought the benefits
that that brings to
not only humans, but the
rest of life on earth.
Well, listen, Ethan, thank you so much.
I appreciate you giving
us all this insight,
all this wisdom.
Thanks man.